il fait déjà partie de temple de la
renommée doigts qui maintenant il doit
il fait partie de l'histoire du quartier
ça fait cinquante et un agent que tu es
mon ami et mon capitaine et l'idole de
tout un peuple
enfin nous sentons un grand vide dans
notre coeur le souvenir avec toi seront
jamais oubliés
ce retour pour nous tous le grand jean
béliveau jeun les roquettes étaient six
à la table d'honneur de nos légendes
nationales
il tint vais te dire in fine ce soir ses
côtés il fut le premier joueur de hockey
a patiné d'un bout à l'autre de la glace
avec la coupe stanley afin que chacun
des partisans puissent se rapprocher du
grand trophée et de la victoire du ch
voit qui est venu nous sauver nous
trions ouverte n'oublieront genre notre
frère
le
m
non
benton cérémonie à son image d'un homme
avec énormément de classe et puis ça a
été fait avec beaucoup de respect c'est
important pour moi
cédric si aujourd'hui de voir le respect
que tous les dignitaires qui avait sur
place les joueurs et les anciens joueurs
wii les joueurs et lui dit
l'organisation dans l'ensemble tout le
respect il a géré le son comme en sont
fiers de la famille